I'm gonna take a second to be completely
open and honest with you guys to be
completely Frank unfiltered this is a
pure train of thought from start to
finish but it's an opportunity for me to
talk to you in a way that I haven't in
years I have been lying to myself in a
weird way I've realized this and it's
not that I'm in a bad place right now
I'm in a very good place let me make
that very clear I'm in a great place
right now I'm at the top of my game I
have been making some incredible stuff I
have the opportunity to make literally
whatever I want whenever I want and that
is an incredible feeling and not only do
I have that I have the skills to back it
up I've been working my ass off for
six-and-a-half years to get to this
point with this fire burning inside my
soul to get to this point where I have
the skillset necessary to make great
videos and that is something that
absolutely nobody can deny I make [ __ ]
videos but I can make and there's a
distinct difference in that but in doing
so and in those years I've reached this
conclusion that I do not necessarily
take myself at face value and that's
something that I want to change and it's
not a big change in any capacity it's
not something that's going to be
earth-shattering but it is something
that requires me to take the first step
and the first step is telling you guys
what's been missing and honestly what's
been missing is this these moments I
used to all the time turn on a camera
and just absolutely uncut ramble 100%
let the madness inside of my mind spill
out of my mouth into a weird string of
incoherent sentences that allows me to
express Who I am because in a very
selfish way this channel is me it is a
perfect representation of the madness
inside my mind and the ambition inside
my soul everything that I am everything
that I've ever done every single
motion in nuance of the person that I
not only want to be but have become is
laid out bare in the videos that I have
made that is me but one thing's been
missing you know that one thing's been
very clearly missing in all of that I've
been doing great videos great like like
in almost short films in terms of
Wilfred mother-loving work session I've
got great plans to do even bigger and
better things along the way but one of
the things that's been missing is this
this pure and simple unadulterated flow
of thoughts the honesty the me of it the
soul behind the channel the the the
personality behind the person you know I
used to be someone that wanted to be
someone else I wanted to be markiplier
so badly because markiplier represented
everything that I wanted to be and so
mark took the backseat you know what I
mean
and the realization isn't that I was
trying to be someone else I was trying
to learn who I was in six-and-a-half
years of doing this I have lived more of
my life than I have in the entire 29
years of my life this journey on YouTube
has taught me more about myself than
anything ever in the history of who I
was and a few things that I've learned
about myself are things that are very
beneficial to what I do on YouTube
number one first and foremost is I
generally just don't give a [ __ ] and
that's good and bad when it comes down
to like negativity and criticism I just
don't give a [ __ ] but in other ways too
on the positive side it can allow me to
seem like I just don't give a [ __ ] what
people think bad or good and that's not
necessarily true in all honesty no one
will ever be a bigger critic of myself
than I am so what would someone else's
opinion about me matter in the least but
I do care about what this channel has
brought about like there's no denying
that this channel is one of the biggest
one of the most lively one of the best
community channels in the entire
ecosystem of YouTube and I'm very proud
to say that I don't care if people
disagree with that doesn't matter to me
I'm proud of
what we've accomplished on this channel
and that's not to say that everyone else
is [ __ ] by comparison I'm proud of what
I have done but then again I haven't had
this opportunity to just talk with you
guys to open up the dialogue between you
I blue moon all the time like boo
[ __ ] hoo like that's not what it's
about that's an excuse I realized that
just like just these past few days I've
really been boiling up inside my mind
because I've been like really thinking
of the different ways that I can make
videos to interact with people to make
the members feel like they're there that
they're respected and and like give them
rewards for what they do and then again
not make sure that the subscribers who
you guys have been following me since
the beginning feel like you've been left
behind I don't want that dissonance
between it and it made me realize that I
just haven't been talking I haven't been
talking to you guys I haven't been
honest I haven't been open I haven't had
this dialogue that has always been so
important to me I have not spoken my
mind I have not said the things that are
on my heart the things that are weighing
down on my soul I have not mentioned
them I haven't gotten emotional about my
own thoughts in forever and I don't know
what started that I don't know what did
it I think it's almost this obsession
with quality of mind that has led me to
not do this because in a weird way it
seems almost juvenile to do it but it's
so important to what I am - Who I am -
what this channel represents about me it
is so important that I'm able to do this
fundamental thing this simplistic thing
that seems like [ __ ] but on its
surface or below its surface is so much
more this this right here is the
lifeblood of this channel is what keeps
it moving through the darkness I've
talked in the past about this fire that
burns inside you this fire that keeps
you going through thick and thin this
fire that pushes you through hardship
towards your goal always moving for
and this fire catches with other people
where you guys have believed in me and
believed in what I do in the same way
that I believe that anybody can
accomplish their goals if they're
willing to sacrifice enough and it's a
decision that you have to make is that
sacrifice worth the chance at something
better and for me the answer is always
yes
always always yes it's why I say I
wouldn't care if my channel died
tomorrow that's not to say I don't care
about the channel I don't care because I
know me as a person would never ever
give up and so when I move forward and
when I came out of my slump from last
year and I I'm moving to these bigger
projects that I can do it makes me
realize that that that something more is
out there you know I used to think that
that I'd reached my goals that I had
gotten to the point where I wanted to be
that I had reached the mountaintop and
yet I know now the six and a half years
that I've been doing this is nothing
it's absolutely nothing you want to know
why I feel like I'm in a good place now
I finally have a goal beyond what I have
here there's no denying the success of
this channel we have so many subscribers
to the point where numbers don't even
mean anything anymore but that's not
what it's about
that's never been what it's about and I
realized that I realized the obsession
with numbers it's what's going to be the
death of YouTube and the death of any
platform and the death of any creator
that gets too tied up in the success of
it the shining accolades the presence I
don't give a [ __ ] about awards awards
shows they can all go burn I don't care
if there's one thing in the world that
doesn't mean anything
it's opinions opinions don't mean [ __ ]
action means something taking those
opinions to heart executing those
opinions making those opinions happen
making those ideas happen that's what
matters but ideas by themselves wither
and die in the darkness but when you
take them out and you set them to flame
you can make anything happen
what people can make the inspiration
that people take from that the ability
for someone to go even farther than they
ever imagined them going the ability for
people to push themselves beyond their
means look at me who honestly look at me
as an example look who I was six and a
half years ago look how far I came
because I made the decision to struggle
every single day every single [ __ ]
day to work towards something that I
wanted I didn't even know what it was
that I wanted it changed all the time
what I wanted but I knew I wanted
something better I knew I wanted to
improve myself I knew that there was a
way to put goodwill love understanding
caring into the world out there and I
knew there was a way to do that through
a medium that people could at the same
time get joy from and I'm still doing it
I'm still doing it to this day I love
that I honestly truly 1% love that it's
my favorite thing and it all starts here
I know that it can be hard to get a read
on Who I am as person it's hard for me
too I'm always changing I'm always
changing what I want I'm always changing
where I'm going my priorities always
change but at the core of it what's
important to me is being honest
not just with you guys but with myself
being honest about what I want being
open about it telling you guys about it
making you feel like you're included in
this because you are like you've never
not been but it just didn't seem like
that you know and that's what I want to
change I know I'm still young but I've
never not thought about what I'm gonna
leave behind after I die I always think
about that I don't fascinate I'm not
fascinated by my own death you know I'm
not morbid like that but I just
recognized the idea behind it
I recognize that what I do is temporary
but what I leave behind is forever who
knows what tomorrow is gonna bring I
don't know I don't even care I've got my
plans and I know there's gonna be
upended plans all over
place spilling out onto the road as this
train crashes down but while I'm here
I'm gonna make a difference and
hopefully you will do so thank you
everybody so much for watching I do want
to make more of these just talking vlogs
more often I miss it I miss you so thank
you for being here and thank you for
watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye